real quick you mentioned new york i i
mean i'm from connecticut new york is
closer
is there a reason why you like you
prefer new york over la
i just think that
there is so much stage time here
and it's going to be frustrating it's a
lot of it feels really bad and you're
going to travel a lot but you can really
like
you can bomb an obscurity here without
industry really paying attention to you
where i think in l.a it sounds like a
industry a lot of industry can be in
some of these shows
that you're going to be on that might
you might go up a little too early and
it is weird it's like
if you don't do well they kind of
remember and it's it's
unfair to base you off of one set and i
feel like in new york
you can just experiment and kind of
figure out who you
are a little bit and be in the community
more
and i i just feel like you just got you
got to move to one of the bigger cities
because
i mean in people are lazy they'd rather
just go look in their backyard for
talent than like go
around the country and figure it out and
then you're gonna get most of your work
from comics rather than industry and
it's
from them that's um hyping you up is
what's going to get you
work so i i say surround yourself with
talented people
hmm gold
well thank you amanda i'm so glad we
were able to do this
thanks for asking great questions people
are cheering you on a lot of people
saying yeah amanda and giving you
applause
yeah moved to new york but and things
are opening up we have a lot of outdoor
shows now so
oh really um and rent's probably gonna
be coming down so i'd say take advantage
in the next few months if we have our
together
with the pandemic yeah
good i'll see i'll see i would love to
new york is awesome thank you so much
for for answering questions and chatting
thank you joel yeah absolutely amanda
yeah yeah thanks for hanging out